let's talk about the healthiest oils to
use when you're deep frying
okay now the oils that you should avoid
when deep frying are the unsaturated
type because
those are very unstable and they oxidize
very easily especially when you
heat them and that would be the soy oil
the canola
the corn the cotton seed the sunflower
seed oil
the safflower seed oil as well as the
peanut oil
and so there's a certain chemical
compound that's created
when you heat or fry these
unsaturated very delicate oils it's a
bit of a mouthful
but it's advanced lipid
oxidation end products now and these are
compounds that have negative effects on
your heart
and there's even a chance that it can
increase your risk for getting certain
types of cancer
and some of the effects are more
damaging than
consuming sugar there's also a study
that i included down below that
demonstrated that
it can slow down autophagy which is the
recycling
of all damaged proteins in the body and
your mitochondria so that's not good
all right so here are the best oils to
use when you're de-frying things
coconut oil or palm oil some people
don't like to use palm oil then great
then don't use it use coconut oil
tallow that is uh fat from beef i
recommend doing the grass
fed beef fat versus the grain fed
beef fat because it's going to be
healthier talo is an ingredient that we
used to use
way back it's loaded with vitamin b3
niacin it's actually it's a good fat to
fry with
number three ghee not butter but ghee
this is
clarified butter they filter out all the
salads
and they get rid of those and you're
just having this pure fat it's a very
good
fat to fry with number four olive oil
now even though the olive oil does have
some unsaturated fats
it seems to be okay for cooking as long
as you keep it below about 400 degrees
and avocado oil is another oil that you
can
fry with that seems to be fairly stable
but these fats will not turn into this
compound
and so they're more stable so they're
not going to oxidize as fast
and they're going to be safer when
they're heated
all right thanks for watching before you
go if you have a question about a
product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help